today's episode is sponsored by blinkist
the app that lets you
read or listen to an entire nonfiction
book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
below this video
let's get right into it normally i would
waste a ton of time at the top of the
show
talking about the show but we actually
have too much show today so let's just
get right into it
um i'm a little worried that there are
too many people on the left who were not
seriously looking at joe biden's
proposals and platform particularly
his economic proposals not looking at
them seriously enough
and giving credit where credit is due
for what yes would be the most
progressive economic platform
of an american president in decades and
decades and i would argue even going
beyond
the high marginal tax rates of
eisenhower's administration and i'll
explain why in a little bit
there's a very good piece in marketwatch
called liberals aren't giving joe biden
credit
for a radical tax plan that goes after
the indolent rich the article is by nick
buffy we're linking to it on youtube i
encourage you to read it
and the article accurately points out as
i've been pointing out for
months that there is a contingent of the
left that is branding joe biden as sort
of like the ultimate centrist
the epitome of the um
uh democratic candidate who is
almost a republican or would have been a
republican in times past
i think that that could not be further
from the truth now i've said
this phrase it would be the most
progressive economic platform in modern
political history and there were people
writing me saying
david it's meaningless because it's
2020. what how is that meaningless
it's accurate okay you can say times
have changed and our expectations
have moved to the left and that's a good
thing and therefore it is also a good
thing
if our elected officials are following
the movement
of the country politically and the
concern
for me is coming partially from i think
that there are some on the left who are
just ideologically blinded
and then there are others who just
aren't looking at the proposals so
let's focus in on the tax proposals that
joe biden has
separate yourself from ideology
and separate yourself from what would be
the perfect
and analyze what is joe biden's platform
joe biden
would raise the corporate profit tax and
establish
what is effectively a minimum tax for
corporations similar to the alternative
minimum tax that people have had
since individuals have had since 1969.
that
is radical in a context where both
parties have allowed the zero
tax dollar status quo of corporations to
perpetuate
itself joe biden would eliminate
deductions
for high income earners joe biden would
repeal
most of the trump tax cuts and increase
taxes on fossil fuel
emissions so uh joe biden would
uncap starting at four hundred thousand
dollars
the 12 tax uh for social security
that is absolutely massive i actually
don't think for a moment i'm going to
imagine
it's not that people don't care it's
that people don't understand the
magnitude of that
you would see a ceo who earns
10 million dollars a year go from paying
a 0.2 percent effective social security
tax
to a 12 effective social security tax
that is a massively radical proposal
which you will see
all sorts of people uh fight tooth and
nail to prevent
from becoming a reality and then joe
biden would take those revenues
and reinvest them in raising social
security benefits for the poor
that's exactly the type of policy that a
bernie sanders type
would put in place there are hundreds of
thousands of seniors who would be
immediately pulled out of poverty
as a result of that policy without it
costing the middle class a penny
some say a dime i say a penny as we know
capital gains is something that allows
the super rich who don't
work to pay less as an effective tax
rate
than many people who do work capital
gains long-term capital gains
taxed at a far lower rate than earned
income
for the rich joe biden has proposed
eliminating that lower capital gains
rate on dividends and long-term
capital gains for everybody making above
a million dollars per year
if you combine that with raising the top
tax rate back to close to 40 percent
that is a combination of proposals from
joe biden
which would nearly double the average
tax rate for non-working
millionaires the tax policy center has
analyzed this proposal
and has found that three quarters of joe
biden's tax increases
would fall on the one percent on the top
one percent
and a lot of that remaining 25 would
fall
on the top two to four percent this is
serious stuff
this is serious radical stuff the people
that then come in and say well he'll
never get it done
but hold on that that's not just joe
biden every president has
trouble getting done what they want to
do and you would have to apply that
exact same standard that exact same
logic that exact same caveat
to bernie sanders you can say well it's
not
left enough okay but say that
and recognize that it would be the most
progressive economic policy for a
sitting president for a long long time
there will be people who come in and say
but the top marginal tax rate was up in
the 90s during dwight d eisenhower's
presidency
yes but the amount of loopholes
available at that time and remember
the alternative minimum tax was not put
in place until 1969.
so prior to that even with these high
sticker tax rates under eisenhower
the very rich were rarely paying
anything close to that because of the
amount of loopholes and because of the
lack of
what's called the alternative minimum
tax so
you can critique joe biden in saying he
doesn't go far enough for example joe
biden wants to
reinstate some of those state and local
tax deductions
that donald trump got rid of there is no
doubt
that there are sort of medium wealthy
and super wealthy people in blue states
that lost some significant deductions
when
trump capped state and local tax
deductions and
yes both the democratic and republican
party
are beholden to donors and that is
something joe biden wants to
reinstate but contrast it with the
magnitude of the other things that he's
proposing to do
so criticize joe biden for not going far
enough
contextualize that we have two very
corporate parties that control
politics in this country do all of that
stuff but
let's not be blind because of ideology
or laziness or lack of curiosity
these are some pretty radical proposals
here and whether or not joe biden can
get it done
that's a different question trump hasn't
gotten done the things he promised
bernie would not be able to get done the
things he wanted to do
elizabeth warren would have had i mean i
don't know how you pass a wealth tax i
really don't
but we have to judge by what the
platforms are
and this is very serious stuff in in any
case
you are going to have no opportunity
if donald trump gets another four years
this is not
you know the lesser of two evils
there is clearly a better option here
and it is not a small margin
it is a dramatic margin between what
donald trump wants to do and has done on
taxes
and what joe biden's proposal proposing
just the facts my friends just the facts
i have some interesting clips for you of
fox news host chris wallace
calling out republican senator tom
cotton for the obvious
brazen bold-faced stunning hypocrisy by
republicans
on the replacement of ruth bader
ginsburg to the supreme court
these clips i'm going to play for you
are not notable because we're
shocked that republicans are being
hypocrites the clips are notable because
of how
casually and comfortably republicans
like tom cotton
use obvious bad arguments
for why they couldn't fill antonin
scalia's seat
back in 2016 but now they should fill
ruth bader ginsburg's seat with only 45
days remaining before the election now
as a reminder
when antonin scalia passed away during
barack obama's presidency
republicans control the senate as they
do now and they blocked
the replacement of antonin scalia with
merrick garland who was barack obama's
choice that was with nine months before
the election
now we have just 44 days before the
election and republicans are saying now
it makes perfect sense for donald trump
to replace ruth bader ginsburg so let's
get into it
here is chris wallace using tom cotton's
own words against him or at least trying
to
back in 2016 after justice scalia died
president obama
named federal judge merrick garland
as his new nominee to the court and as
you well know you were part of the
senate then
senate republicans blocked the choice of
garland
here's what you said at that time
in a few short months we will have a new
president and new senators
who can consider the next justice with
the full faith
of the american people why would we cut
off the national debate
about this next justice why would we
squelch the voice
of the people why would we deny the
voters a chance to weigh in on the
makeup of the supreme court
now garland was nominated nine months
before the election and you were saying
then
nine months before the election it was
wrong to deny voters
a chance to weigh in so if it was wrong
then nine months before the election
why is it okay now six weeks before the
election
so chris in 2014 the american people
elected republic
a republican majority of the senate to
put the brakes on president obama's
judicial nominations
in 2018 we had a referendum on this
question just a month before the 2018
midterms
we had the vote on justice kavanaugh
there could not have been a clear
mandate because the american people
didn't just re-elect republicans they
expanded our majority
they defeated four democratic senators
who voted against justice kavanaugh they
reelected the one democratic senator
who did vote for justice kavanaugh so we
have a clear
mandate to perform our constitutional
duty that's what the senate majority
will do now
that's what we did back in 2016 as well
this is one of the biggest logic
pretzels that i've ever seen from
republicans it actually
boggles the mind if you're not sure what
tom cotton is talking about that's
exactly the point it's meant to be
confusing let's think it through
tom cotton says there's no hypocrisy
here
because right after kavanaugh's
confirmation
there was a midterm election in 2018 and
republicans gained seats showing that
the public had no problem
with the confident confirmation of brett
kavanaugh this is
a complete non-sequitur it has nothing
to do with the issue at hand
first of all the senate only has one
third of the seats up for re-election
every election cycle one-third of the
senate
is up for re-election in any given
election year
in 2018 the senate seats up for
re-election
favored republicans it had nothing to do
with
some kind of american referendum on
whether or not it was okay to fill brett
kavanaugh see i mean
it has it has nothing to do with it it
is a complete and total red herring
secondly this is about presidents not
senates
they said obama can't pick someone
during his last year
and now they're saying trump can pick
someone
during what are the last 44 days before
the election
it is incoherent and chris wallace calls
him out
you really don't think there is any
hypocrisy at all
in saying we need to give voters because
i mean you can parse the 2014 election
the 2018 election any way you want
but you stated a pretty firm principle
in 2016 about merrick garland
it's wrong to deny voters a chance to
weigh in you don't see any hypocrisy
between that position then in this
position now
chris the senate majority is performing
our constitutional duty and fulfilling
the mandate that the voter
voters gave us in 2016 and especially
in 2018. i i just
wanna i promise this is the last
question on this particular subject
let's do a thought experiment you're a
lawyer you do hypotheticals or you did
when you were in law school
let's assume if president trump were to
lose
in the election six weeks from now if
the senate were to change hands so that
it went from republicans to democrats in
a lame duck session
with a president who'd been defeated and
a republican majority that was about to
be
out of office some would say the lamest
of lame duck sessions are you saying you
still
think it would be proper to vote to
confirm president trump's nominee to the
court
chris as i said we're going to move
forward without delay and there will be
a vote on this nominee
these are just bad people that's it
chris wallace exposes the hypocrisy he
does
i don't know that it matters to the fox
news audience donald trump has coined
this new uh refrain at his rallies
fill that seat and they are moving
forward
and unfortunately it looks like they're
going to have the numbers to do it
so we can't control everything but
we can control voting in november
and we all need to get out and vote
to end this insanity they may get this
seat filled they may not ultimately
you know we can only do so much and we
should do whatever we can do
but they need to be punished tom cotton
needs to be punished
lindsey graham needs to be punished he's
got an opponent jamie harrison
these people need to be held accountable
for their hypocrisy for their brazen
double standards
and chris wallace is trying but they
just don't care
at the end of the day they do not care
that they are obvious hypocrites
let me know your thoughts i'm on twitter
at d pacman remember you can get the
daily audio podcast
anywhere you want itunes stitcher
spotify pandora don't miss it the david
pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time
of course by the great stephen hawking
this is a book that i have been aware of
for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different
non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks
a month and you get the entire library
but you can try it totally free and get
25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
so donald trump has started a new
routine where he calls
into fox and friends every monday
morning fox and friends of course is
this fox propaganda
morning show uh the format is two male
hosts and a female host and it's kind of
like a mix of
completely hare-brained depraved
propaganda with the optics of
daytime television and the idea of trump
calling in every monday is that it's
ostensibly
good for everybody fox and friends hosts
get their face time with the president
trump gets a softball interview and
everybody is better for it
other than the country and the world but
sadly it did not go
super well yesterday we're going to look
at a few clips and check
out the looks on the faces of the hosts
of fox and friends when trump goes into
these
bizarre screeds and unconscionable
diatribes
the looks on the faces of the hosts are
of people sick to their stomachs and
it actually reminded me watching these
clips of when
remember when uh former new jersey
governor chris christie
dropped out of the republican primary in
2016
and then endorsed trump and like the
next day showed up and stood behind
trump during one of these stump speeches
and chris christie just looked like he
had eaten a bad oyster he looked sick
same idea here with the fox host so get
let's get right into it trump was asked
about
of course ruth bader ginsburg and what
is trump's rationale
for trying to push through her
replacement
before election day and trump's answer
was well democrats would do it if given
the chance
trump also you will notice has a
terrible phone connection might even be
on speakerphone just everything going
wrong
don't forget we were put in this
position by voters
and we have a lot of time it's not like
we have two days we have a lot of time
as this goes
whether it's before or after i think it
should we have a lot of time before
i think it should go before but whether
it's before or after
i mean after we have a lot of time but i
think we should do it before
but we you know so you might do it in
the same position
there is zero chance that they wouldn't
do it just so you understand so you're
putting it on the
tactical courts so if you were on the
other foot if there was a democratic
president and a democrat senate you
think they would
they would definitely fill the seat
before
oh zero chance that they wouldn't they
would do it they wouldn't even talk
about it
fox and friends host ainsley erhart
there trying to help trump out
now this is a terrible argument trump
has
run the country and campaigned for years
on elect me because i won't do what
democrats do
elect me because i i won't do what
democrats would
do if given the chance and now trump
says well the reason i'm going to do
this is democrats would do it
i thought the point was you don't behave
like democrats
you say democrats do the wrong thing and
now
you're justifying your actions by saying
well it's what democrats would do
very backwards logic but unfortunately
for the fox crowd they eat it up like
it's being ladle fed to them
maybe the most disgusting moment of the
interview
donald trump sort of laughed off ruth
bader ginsburg's
dying wish that she not be replaced
until a new president has been seated
inaugurated
donald trump without any evidence
whatsoever this is sick
says i don't know if that's true adam
schiff
might have made that up out of thin air
nancy pelosi
might have made that up out of thin air
take a look at this charlie was on our
show earlier and he said we have an
obligation to our to our voters
to vote the way they want us to vote
that's why they put us in office so he's
gonna push to to go ahead and fill the
seat um
either before the election or in the
lane duck session then you have
ruth bader ginsburg who told her her
granddaughter on her deathbed allegedly
that she
um her dying wish was to have the next
president choose her successor
how do you think all this plays out
well i don't know that she said that or
was that written out by adam schiff
and schumer and pelosi i i would be more
inclined to the second okay you know
that came
out of the wind it sounds so beautiful
but that sounds like a schumer deal or
maybe a pelosi or
or uh shifty shift so that came out of
the wind let's see i mean maybe she did
it maybe she did
look the bottom line is we won the
election of course
no doubt whatsoever there's no reason to
think
that the official story is false if it
were
a made-up story it certainly wouldn't be
trump who could tell us oh it was adam
schiff who came up with the story
imagine the absurdity of this claim
ruth bader ginsburg didn't really say
what she said on her deathbed
a random congressman from california
adam schiff made it up
disgusting absolutely disgusting and
again
you look at the online pro-trump
enclaves they they actually say yeah you
know trump might be onto something here
sounds fake doesn't sound real with 200
000 now dead from coronavirus and we're
going to talk more about this actually
204 thousand
donald trump says during this bizarre
interview
we've turned the corner on the pandemic
and trump grades his coronavirus
response an a
plus this was as they were talking uh
the stock market futures down 700 points
because of the resurgence of the virus
that's expected trump saying we get an
a-plus take a look
you're going to get on air force one
you're flying out to ohio today you're
going to address the
fight for the american worker ever since
the pandemic
started and the economy cratered
the federal reserve you know looking
forward they were a little pessimistic
but a couple of days ago
the federal reserve actually was quite
optimistic and in fact
they talked about how right now we're in
a situation where we have
three million more jobs than they
thought we would at this
stage of the game that's right and 600
billion dollars more
economic activity over and above what
they expected just three months ago
so while we are still suffering from the
pandemic
there is some light at the end of the
tunnel
so we're rounding the corner with or
without a vaccine they hate it when i
say that but that's the way it is we're
rounding the corner
on the pandemic and we've done a
phenomenal job not just a good job a
phenomenal job other than public
relations but that's because i have fake
news i can't you know you
you can't convince them of anything
they're fake but
we have done on on public relations i
give myself a d
on the job itself we take an a plus a
plus trump says on the virus now
reminders
let's come back to earth cases per
capita the us's 12th highest in the
world
if you take out tiny territories the us
is eighth highest in the world
in cases per capita deaths per capita
10th highest in the world is the united
states eighth highest in the world
if you exclude tiny territories trump
says i get an a-plus
trump admits later in this interview
that he is playing politics in
considering
who to replace ruth bader ginsburg with
looking at michigan looking at florida
admitting it
election day so maybe she gets the nod
is
is is politics going to be part of it
i try not to say so i think probably
automatically it is even if you're not
wanting to do that it becomes a little
automatic a great one from michigan
you know you talked that as you know
indiana
represented very well we have uh from
all over the country
i think less so than the person
themselves if you look at
and then trump jokes because everything
is a joke
everything is a game everything is a
popularity contest
trump jokes about putting fox and
friends host ainsley earhart
on the supreme court after saying
that you know ruth bader ginsburg did
support me in her decision once
everything with trump is what have you
done for him
she was you know a legendary a legal
figure i'm sure you have some things
you'd like to say about
how this woman had given decades of her
life to public service
well she was a legend and she
represented something different than
you or i or somebody else may really
agree with or
were like frankly but she was a legend
she represented
a certain philosophy policy
certain groups of laws she represented
them very well
highly respected she actually voted for
me in a very important case
and i was shocked if you want another
truth because we lost
a couple of conservative votes and she
actually made it possible to get this
approved which was rather amazing to be
honest with you i
i don't want to hurt her reputation at
all but she did vote for me in a case
that was a very important case
so that was nice but uh no she was a
legendary figure
well i know you said you're going to
nominate a woman that's very important
to
uh women who are voting in november uh
for women's rights
you said you angelie i could nominate
you you know you don't have to be
you don't have to be a lawyer you don't
have to be a judge i could nominate
some news right now funny guy right but
but again
it's not a joke that with trump it's
always about
what did the person do for me what can i
expect them to do for me
what do they think about me do they like
me have they helped me
that's what matters to trump and i
again i don't know if these fox and
friends interviews do any good do any
harm
but they are stunning from the
standpoint
of basic human decency it didn't get
much better
later last night at one of donald
trump's two rallies in ohio let's talk
about that briefly next
so donald trump had two events yesterday
in ohio big crowds
lots of virus flying around and
i want to focus in on the second event
here donald trump did one event at
dayton's airport
and then later drove about an hour north
to some other part of ohio and did an
event later on in the day
donald trump uh continues to just lie
about coronavirus coronavirus has now
killed more than 204
000 people in the united states it
doesn't matter trump insists
he's done great we're doing great and he
actually has the audacity to say
coronavirus affects virtually nobody
that's a quote 204 almost 205 000
dead americans trump says it affects
the virtually we didn't know it
now we know it it affects elderly people
elderly people with heart problems and
other problems
if they have other problems that's what
it really affects that's it
you know in some states thousands of
people
nobody young below the age of 18
like nobody they have a strong immune
system who knows
you look at you take your hat off to the
young because they have a hell of an
immune system
but it affects virtually nobody it's a
it's an amazing thing by the way open
your schools everybody open your school
it affects virtually nobody can you
imagine imagine having lost
family members to coronavirus and
hearing trump say
it affects virtually nobody
two americans died of ebola and donald
trump called for barack obama's
resignation
204 000 americans have died of this
virus and trump is saying
we get an a plus he said that to fox
news earlier in the day yesterday
and we are seeing the virus affect
virtually
nobody you decide whether this is
someone who's earned four more years
trump still struggling to just speak
english
still unable to pronounce ulysses s
grant
annie oakley william mckinley
and the amazing ulysses s grant that's
good
that's a sort of like a packaged section
of speech
that trump is using a lot where he just
lists american
historical figures the crowd actually
seems to like it and it's not surprising
if you see who
if you look at who's willing to be
crowded together for hours right now
given what's going on with the virus
it's not surprising that some of those
same people
react positively and cheer when trump
just names historical figures
trump then encouraging the crowd to
report
unsolicited mail-in ballots to
authorities
what if you're confused i'm confused
it's unclear what he's
actually asking people to do the great
state of ohio
so get your friends get your family
get your neighbors get your co-workers
get everybody
and get out and vote got to get out and
and in your state in ohio early voting
has already begun
and don't wait and when you see them
cheating on the other side i don't say
if when
when you see them cheating with those
ballots all of those unsolicited ballots
those millions of ballots you see them
anytime you do
report them to the authorities the
authorities are waiting and watching
report unsolicited ballots
sent to other people
and importantly to stay with the facts
and to stay with reality
ohio isn't sending unsolicited absentee
ballots what ohio decided to do
is to send out ballot applications
if you want an absentee ballot you fill
out the application
and you send it in then you'll get a
ballot if you don't you're not going to
get a ballot plain and simple
then as part of the victimization tour
that continues donald trump continues to
whine and complain that nbc
didn't talk about his nobel prize
nomination they
they instead covered the hurricane that
was ravaging
parts of the country take a look it's a
big deal for our country right
and she said oh that's good i said let's
turn on the evening
let's watch it this is going to be a big
show tonight get ready
an nbc which is one of the most crooked
one of the worst newscasts
and i'm talking about normal nbc not
msdnc
msdnc is the worst but so i turned on
the nbc with lester holt another beauty
and they saw it with a hurricane and
then they went to something
and something else and i'm saying first
lady is getting a little embarrassing
with 20 minutes into a half hour show
they haven't mentioned the nobel peace
prize and then it went through the whole
show and they never mentioned then i got
nominated for a second one they never
mentioned
trump actually seems to think that these
silly nominations
by right-wing politicians most recently
this right-wing politician from norway
nominated trump for a nobel peace prize
he thinks that's real news when there's
a hurricane ravaging people's homes and
lives
in different parts of the country it's
the epitome
of self-centeredness and narcissism that
has become
unfortunately commonplace in american
politics
and then for the second straight
election cycle
trump is campaigning on all the same
stuff he's campaigning on middle-income
tax cuts he's
campaigning on build a wall he's
president now
why can't he do it now take a look
that's got a seat it's got a seat in
and we have a lot of new things
including additional substantial
middle income tax cuts and other tax
cuts
and and tremendous regulation cuts
and we're finishing up with our military
you know we're building space force
the wall is going incredibly this is
part of something we've been covering
for a little while now which is
trump is running like he's not the
president elect me and i'll do tax cuts
elect me and i'll do health care reform
i'll replace obamacare i'll build the
wall i'll fix the suburbs
i'll do enter whatever you know whatever
he's been president for four years why
hasn't he done these things already
he controlled the house and senate for
the first two of those years he's had
the senate
all four years we need to reelect him to
get him to do anything it doesn't make
sense
and then in barely concealed racism
donald trump says that if joe biden wins
biden as well as black senator cory
booker
are going to destroy the suburbs
you know i ended a regulation that will
destroy suburbia
if biden got in they will destroy
the suburbia we call it suburbia
of the world and we love it i know it
well westchester county
the uh suburban they sometimes some
if you say suburban housewife you're in
deep trouble so what you do is you say
suburban women they love me you know why
they want security
and they don't want projects being right
next to their house that's okay
they don't want it and by the way that
includes minorities because
29 to 30 percent of the suburban
communities are minorities
and that includes them they don't want
that they want safe communities they
want great communities they don't want
to have
they don't want to lose the american
dream it's very simple
i got rid of the regulation from
obama biden that was destroying
suburbia okay destroying it
and i think suburbia has got to wake up
because uh
if they get in you know who's in charge
you know who's in charge of the program
corey booker cory booker the crowd
doesn't have any idea what trump is
talking about
i can assure you it doesn't matter
they'll still cheer
sort of half-heartedly and one
bonus clip from trump's earlier event
where he was in dayton ohio
trump tells just a never-ending story
it's five minutes long i'm only going to
play 40 seconds for you
trump goes on an incoherent
unintelligible story
about why steam power is better than
electric power for military ships
i can't make heads or tails out of this
but notice how the the crowd is silent
they don't have any idea what this guy's
talking about the admirals a lot i got a
lot of animals i like the admirals
i want to meet with the catapulters sir
what will you want to meet with the
catapulters for i want to find out why
the hell the catapulters don't work
so i went there and you know they did a
new system it's electric it's all
electric
so instead of steam which is simple and
great
powerful good and they know how it works
for years and years
they decide to go all electric now if
you take a little glass of water take
this glass of water you throw it on and
that's the end of that you bring
somebody in from mit
how the hell do you fix it and we're
dealing with the ocean
and rockets being shot at the ship and
the rough stuff right
but it wasn't working it went on it went
on
and on from there i'm not going to
subject you to all of it
but these events bizarre in every way
and in particular i said this yesterday
kindergarten and first grade teachers
they don't know how to get the whole
class to sit silently trump has figured
out how to do it with a crowd of a
thousand
he can get them to just be silent
almost still like not moving with these
bizarre non-sequitur stories
uh and we are going to see many more of
these rallies this week leading up of
course
to the first presidential debate next
tuesday i will be streaming live
starting at 8 30 p.m eastern time next
tuesday i would love it for you to watch
the debate
with me we will be live on youtube
twitch and facebook that's next week
in the meantime more coverage of these
whacked
rallies on our instagram page david
pakman show
and follow me on instagram at
david.pacman
to see a picture of the beautiful cake
that youtube sent me
for our one million subscriber milestone
a gigantic cake they sent me a cake that
would normally feed
30 people there's a picture of it on my
instagram david.pakman quick break
back after this the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way
is through membership which includes the
world famous bonus show
as well as commercial free audio and
video streams of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpacman.com
coupon code saves you 40 vote soon 18.
[Music]
welcome back to the david pakman show
it's great to welcome back to the
program today thomas frank who is
author of the people know a brief
history of anti-populism
also author of listen liberal and what's
the matter with kansas
and other books uh it's great to have
you back on today
you know david it is my pleasure so
let's to pick a place to start because
we could start in many different places
do you believe that the democratic party
as an institution has accurately
ascertained
why donald trump won in 2016 well no of
course not there they've done
anything but but but examine that
they're uh
they've been in denial ever since that
election now i i think that there is
some
um they understand it it's not hard to
understand you know you've got this uh
large group of voters that has been
moving over to the shifting over to the
republican
party for a long long long time
and uh in reaction to you know these
very predictable things
not not predictable but visible i should
say very highly visible
developments so it's not like it's hard
to understand
what what's going wrong uh but
they are you know you think about uh
they spent
several years investigating uh
you know investigating trump's
supposedly being a
you know some kind of russian agent you
know collusion with the
with the with the russians and you know
whether or not that
look trump's administration is corrupt
eight ways to sunday but
the the the uh the intention there was
always to try to
somehow pin the election results on this
outside actor and
in this way dismiss what happened uh and
so
no they haven't and they've done
anything but
reckon with what happened in 2016 except
for in one way
but it's more subconscious than anything
else and that is the choice of joe biden
i mean biden is actually
i say i i think he's more interesting
than other people do
because he is he does come from this
sort of old-school
uh sort of uh uh working-class
background or at least
you know they tell us that all the time
he used to call himself middle class joe
and he rides the amtrak and on and on
and on
and so in that respect they have chosen
someone who they
think will uh uh will bring back the
uh you know the sort of uh manufacturing
areas that they lost uh
pennsylvania michigan wisconsin maybe
even ohio
and we shall see but that's biden is
basically the one man they could choose
to do that
job without actually going to a sort of
bernie sanders kind of figure
yeah one of the things that i found
interesting is that
there are there's no candidate that is
beyond critique
i am against the deification of any
elected official these are just people
and sometimes we'll agree with them and
sometimes we'll disagree with them
but i think that not enough attention
has been paid which is why i've been
trying to pay attention to
to some of the interesting policy
proposals that joe biden is putting
forward
where i mean listen when you look at
uncapping social security tax at 400
dollars that's that's huge that there
that's radical
in some circles but that's not no one's
gonna notice that or or
you know yeah so that's my question
which is why
is there just is there no piece of the
electorate that actually cares about
something
like economic policy oh my god well of
course they do
care but only only when you deliver the
results i mean of course they
look everybody is you know my grand
theory about
about what's been happening in politics
and i've been writing about it
you know low these many years is that we
are uh we are in fact furious about
economic developments uh you know ever
since the early 1980s this country has
for most people been on a downhill uh
you know on a toboggan ride to nowhere
yeah uh you know the the the
middle-class society that i was born
into is long gone people are furious
about it de-industrialization etc etc
etc
no people don't understand the nuts and
bolts of how that was done
but they do get the big picture uh
absolutely they get it but they
you know something like that it's gonna
be it's gonna be
i mean you can explain it to people in a
way that uh that makes sense and
that is actually compelling you know
that that the rich should pay their fair
share et cetera
but you've got a you've got to have a uh
a whole vision a whole understanding of
uh you know of the of this the situation
that people are in you can't just
promise technocratic fixes that will
you know that that'll that'll that'll
you know make the machine run slightly
more smoothly
and i hate to say it but this is kind of
donald trump's
strength is that he talks like uh you
know
he's constantly complaining even though
he's president yeah he could beat the
plane's cause i was just reading
something the other day where he was
he was uh he was actually blaming some
policy disaster on biden and it's
something that's like happy
right now and it's like how could biden
is like you know in his basement in
delaware he hasn't been in office in
years how could he
possibly be held responsible this is
just trump's way of talking you know
well i wanted to ask about that because
i did a segment a couple of weeks ago
talking about how
donald trump has adopted rhetoric of
even though he's president
running as if someone else is president
and you should elect him you know
he's like if you get if you re-elect me
i'll build the wall
i'll fix taxes i'll do healthcare but
also he thinks this way or he appears to
i mean
i don't know how much his you know you
should how much emphasis you should put
on his twitter feed but like uh
here's a guy that keeps talking about
like how
somebody should do something about
google right it's like
you probably you're the president just
you know call your
attorney general into the room and
instruct him to go get those guys
it's really not hard but my question
about the running as if he's not
president
is who is that tailored to appeal to is
that tailored to appeal to people who
aren't paying close attention
is it tailored to appeal to to his
existing base to moderates what what is
the what is it about
clearly the first criteria is is people
who
as you as you just said who aren't
paying much attention because that's
that's that one
it just doesn't it just that doesn't
i don't think that works for very many
people you know you it's
it's that's a that's a a silly little
psychological trick that is not that i
think is not going to succeed
i mean look this guy is there's also a
um
a bit of wish fulfillment uh there this
guy is
his his tenure in office has been
nothing short of disastrous i mean look
where we are
yes hundreds of thousands of people have
died the economy is basically shut down
uh you know you've got uh uh protests
and uh uh you know violence in the
streets all over the place
and uh some president this guy you know
he can't do anything about any of it or
or
you know he could but he's just utterly
incompetent and unsuited to the office
i'm 55 years old david and
i've seen something we've seen some
incompetent presidents i i often think
of jimmy carter you know who just got
so badly swamped after one term in
in 1980 and uh this guy is way
beyond that jimmy carter looks really
like
wonderful by comparison to donald trump
jimmy carter really
cared he was really trying hard it's
just nothing worked for him you know
but this guy oh my god he doesn't have
any
idea what he's doing we're going to
pause our conversation with thomas frank
there the entire conversation will be
available on the david pakman show
youtube channel this weekend at
youtube.com
slash the david pakman show the david
pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going is through
patreon
where you can pledge as little as one
dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
pakman show great perks and benefits as
well
read about him
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
this next story is absolutely insane
it's dystopian it's it's really straight
out of a handmaid's tale much like some
of the people donald trump is
considering
for the supreme court to replace ruth
bader ginsburg although we'll get to
them
on tomorrow's show but it is now alleged
that the united states in 2020 under
donald trump
is performing forced sterilization
unwanted hysterectomies
on women detained by donald trump's ice
immigrations and customs enforcement
forced
sterilization is what we are talking
about here
prism has learned according to a source
familiar with the situation
that gynecologist mahendra amin
based in georgia has been performing
forced
sterilizations as per prism the
organization's project
south the georgia detention watch
georgia latino alliance for human rights
and georgia a south georgia immigrant
support network
have filed a complaint on behalf of
immigrants detained
by the united states detained inside of
icdc
which is operated by private prison
company
lasalle corrections and the organization
alleges that
five women could be more but this
specific complaint refers to five women
sterilized at the facility between
october and december of last year don
wooten a licensed practical nurse
employed
by icdc is the whistleblower
and she says i've had several inmates
tell me that they've been to see the
doctor
and they've had hysterectomies and they
don't know why they went
or why they're going a spokesperson for
the southern poverty law center
which has represented people detained
there confirmed to prison
that dr amin saw multiple women
represented by the organization the
spokesperson couldn't currently
uh confirm the extent of the
appointments and according to the
whistleblower in the project south
complaint
amine recently took out the wrong ovary
on a detained woman the women do not
appear to be consenting to getting
hysterectomies they are not receiving
translation services many times there
are language barriers
when they are getting complicated
medical information conveyed to them
they have no
translator sometimes nurses are
reportedly communicating
using google voice on their phones to
translate google translate on their
phones rather
or by asking other detainees to
translate that's not how we do things
or i thought we weren't doing things
that way in the united states
and one woman was given three different
explanations about what is being done
to her medically this is some of the
ugliest stuff that we've heard of
there if you go back and look at u.s
history
there is an ugly history of reproductive
injustice in the united states
the tuskegee experiment used uh
african-american
sharecroppers to test and understand
syphilis with researchers refusing to
tell patients
that they have syphilis or to treat them
in order to see what happens
with untreated syphilis men were denied
treatment and many died
or went blind or insane the american
doctors behind
the birth control pill first tested the
birth control pill on low-income
puerto rican women there have been
nationwide eugenics campaigns
targeting wide swaths of people for
sterilization because they were
considered undesirable so there's a
history of this and it's happening now
and it gets even worse the doctor
dr mahendra amin appears not to even be
a board-certified ob gyn they are a
gynecologist
but a spokesperson for the american
board of obstetrics and gynecology
said to the daily beast that according
to their records dr
mahendra amin is not even certified now
it's sort of like the icing on the cake
right
shocker that the trump administration's
choice of doctor for forced
sterilizations is not board certified
but it's just another detail in the
insanity
um ice is not commenting about the
certification of dr amin
and we have we are in the process of
trying to figure out
uh what the hell is going on here the
obvious question is is doctor
amin going to be prosecuted probably not
is he going to be made surgeon general
seems like as reasonable of a question
uh given the insanity of this
administration
this really is uh uh th
this is concentration camp stuff um if
it's even a fraction of what's being
alleged
it is the worst of the worst and we
really need to remind ourselves as a
country
that we have committed atrocities in the
past
and we've made improvements but things
are still going on
we can't put our guard down for a moment
the vigilance must stay
and when you let lunatics in power
bad things happen it's not just
elections have consequences
it's also not paying attention even for
a moment
has major consequences human rights
abuses
it it's it's dystopian i'm almost at a
loss for words
and unfortunately we are repeating some
of the worst things from american
history
right now it's having an effect on our
reputation and that's what i want to
talk about next
we've been speaking on the program about
the united states as a global laughing
stock under donald trump
this is not just something i say it's
the truth and we have new data
sometimes when i talk about the united
states as a laughingstock
under trump people write in and say
david the world respects trump the world
knows trump does what's best for us and
they don't like that
because we win and maybe they lose
no the reputation of the united states
is in the toilet
there's a new pew research center study
since donald trump took office as
president the image of the united states
has hugely suffered in many countries
the united states reputation
is at a record low looking at the last
20 years if you look at the uk
france germany japan canada australia
in every single one of those countries
favorability
for the united states is the lowest it
has been in 20 years it is at the worst
point now
that it was throughout the entire bush
presidency
obama presidency and donald trump
presidency
right now right now is the low point the
numbers were already atrocious during
the first three years of trump's
presidency
but it is coronavirus and donald trump's
completely failed response
that has really hurt him in the last six
months
only 15 of 13 major countries
think the united states has done a good
job handling coronavirus
if you look at a chart of confidence in
the american president over time
among western european countries you see
that
it sort of trended down under bush
trust in the american president was much
higher
in western europe during barack obama
and then it dropped
even lower during donald trump than it
was during the george w
bush administration and it makes a lot
of sense if you pay attention to what's
going on
now very interesting if you look at
trust in trump
versus trust in other leaders across
these 13 countries this is based on
australia belgium canada denmark france
germany italy japan
netherlands south korea spain sweden and
the uk
across those 13 countries you see that
the least
trusted leader is donald trump 83
across those 13 countries have no
confidence
in donald trump followed by president xi
of china
and putin of russia in other words putin
and xi
are more trusted than donald trump
on the other end germany's angela merkel
is the most trusted at 76 percent
followed by french president emmanuel
macron
and then boris johnson it is not about
left or right
boris johnson and angela merkel and even
macron
are no extreme liberals it is not about
that
the world recognizes trump is a buffoon
who cannot be trusted
they think we're stupid for voting such
a clown
into office remember that trump said on
twitter back in 2014
we need a president who isn't a laughing
stock to the entire world
we need a truly great leader a genius at
strategy and winning respect
that tweet has never been more relevant
than it is today
trump is less popular and less trusted
than vladimir putin
and president xi of china this is a
pathetic joke
but it's a joke that could last four
more years
the whole we should research taking
bleach internally
that was quite a low point even by
applying the most generous standards to
donald trump
and it has been downhill from there and
things are so bad
i would actually ask conservatives do
you really
want to defend trump four more years or
wouldn't you be better off just
attacking biden for the next four years
like from the standpoint of putting them
in positions
of having to defend the indefensible it
almost seems to me that it would be
better for them
to spend the next four years just
criticizing biden
than continuing to defend the absolute
embarrassment that has been donald
trump's administration i don't know
let me know what you think we have a
voicemail number
that number is 2192 david p
more and more people asking about moving
out of the country take a listen to this
hi david so i've been so terrified
of the possibility of trump getting
another four years that i've been
thinking pretty seriously
about how i would try to leave the
country leave the usa and live in a
different country if that were to happen
yeah um i just think that it would be
safer
so i'm wondering if you have any
advice for people who want to do that do
you remember anything about
your own immigration from argentina
that's
right useful to somebody who is thinking
about
immigrating away from the united states
well yes what i remember
is that there's a reason why most people
don't do it we he we you know we've
heard many times before if bush gets
reelected i'm moving to canada
if obama gets reelected i'm moving i
don't know where they would go but
in any case um most people don't do it
because it's it's insane i mean it's
really it's really a difficult thing
it's
as someone who came to the united states
still young enough to quickly learn the
language and culture
it is a really big thing to abandon your
home
and um this is why you know we shouldn't
take lightly
the fact that people are willing to come
to the united states even illegally
understand
the cataclysmic change that this
represents from them
it is an unimaginable change
and i would be lying if i said i'm
thinking of
relocating permanently if donald trump
gets reelected but
the truth is that it is particularly now
with the mobile studio where i can
basically take
have the exact same sound and video
quality no matter where i go
um i am certainly thinking of if trump
gets reelected we'll be here covering
the lame duck period and and of course
the
the re-election um uh the inauguration
rather
but i am looking at spending some months
doing the show from somewhere else and i
understand that not everybody can do
that not everybody's jobs are mobile not
everybody can afford it
um but it is something i am looking at
just to get a break just to get get get
a break from
uh being in a place where uh constantly
just idiocy is happening so i i think
that
very few people are really going to move
out of the united states if trump is
reelected partially because
it's really cataclysmic change in one's
life partially because
it's really hard to do it you can't just
move to a lot of the places that i think
most americans would look to move to if
they are trying to
uh avoid donald trump but certainly
i'd be lying if uh if if i said it's not
occurring to me to get a break
from the united states if donald trump
does get reelected but we'll
we're going to continue talking about
that and i'm interested in hearing
from the audience about it don't miss
today's bonus show there's another show
for our members
membership is our number one funding
source
grab a membership at joinpakman.com
and i'll see you on today's bonus show
thanks so much for watching today's full
episode of the show just a reminder
today's
sponsor is blinkist the app that lets
you read or listen
to an entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try blinkist for free
and save 25 off of a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com david pakman
i've also included the link right
underneath this video